Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera a tutti.
Durante la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
un ammiraglio francese,
durante una riunione con i suoi ufficiali,
poiché c'era il problema molto serio
dei famigerati
sommergibili tedeschi U-Boot,
che introdussero delle devastazioni
al naviglio degli avversari,
disse, in una riunione, ai suoi ufficiali:
"Voi dovete fare bollire l'acqua del mare,
in maniera tale che gli U-Boot
saranno costretti ad emergere
e noi li potremo catturare".
Al che gli ufficiali fecero presente,
non senza qualche timore reverenziale,
all'Ammiraglio:
"Sì ma esattamente noi come possiamo
fare a far bollire l'acqua del mare?"
E l'Ammiraglio rispose:
"Io mi occupo di strategie
e non di tattiche".
Allora, questo è il preludio
e l'antefatto.
Poi magari spero
che sarà più intelligibile
sulla finale del mio speech,
o in caso, qualcuno,
se vuole chiamare uno psichiatra,
c'è anche la possibilità.
Tra le perversioni che io mi riconosco,
perché ho un discreto
livello di autocoscienza,
c'è anche quella di avere
una profonda ammirazione
per la Confederazione Svizzera
e per le le prassi democratiche
della Confederazione Svizzera.
Nello specifico, per la loro forma
di democrazia diretta,
per la possibilità, quindi,
che i cittadini possano
lanciare dei referendum,
non solo abrogativi ma anche propositivi,
addirittura con
una valenza costituzionale.
Cioè, si va alle urne
e se vince il "Sì" ad un quesito,
si scrive un articolo della Costituzione.
Il che è una cosa molto affascinante,
l'apoteosi della democrazia diretta.
Tre anni fa, esattamente tre anni fa,
nel febbraio del 2014,
i cittadini svizzeri andarono alle urne,
per decidere un quesito
di rango costituzionale,
che prevedeva l'imposizione
di contingenti all'immigrazione,
inclusa l'immigrazione
dall'Unione Europea.
Il referendum finì
con una vittoria di misura,
circa 20.000 voti di scarto,
a favore del "Sì".
Pertanto, venne scritto
un articolo, 121a,
della Costituzione Svizzera,
che stabiliva questo principio.
Ora, in condizioni normali,
quello che è scritto su una Costituzione
dovrebbe avere un seguito operativo
a livello di leggi.
Quindi venne dato
al Parlamento Federale Svizzero
un arco temporale di tre anni
per legiferare.
Subito dopo l'esito
della consultazione referendaria,
gli svizzeri scoprirono,
non senza qualche perplessità,
che loro hanno firmato,
nel corso dei decenni,
decine di accordi bilaterali
con l'Unione Europea,
rispetto i quali la Svizzera
può accedere al Mercato Unico Europeo,
però come contropartita,
tra le altre cose deve dare
la libera circolazione delle persone.
Quindi, da una parte
il nuovo articolo della Costituzione
che parla di contingenti all'immigrazione,
dall'altra parte
tutti gli accordi bilaterali
che sono parte, se volete,
anche della prosperità
della Confederazione.
Quindi la situazione
sfuggì rapidamente di mano,
cioè vi fu un vero e proprio
psicodramma nazionale.
Da una parte quelli che dicevano:
"La Costituzione è sacra,
non bisogna toccarla,
l'esito, il popolo è sovrano", eccetera,
e dall'altra parte quelli che dicevano:
"Guardate che forse abbiamo un problema".
Alla fine, dopo tre anni di sofferenze,
che cosa si è deciso?
Che cosa ha legiferato il Parlamento?
Che in caso di disoccupazione
più alta di una data soglia critica,
che verrà stabilita,
in alcune zone del Paese e rispetto
ad alcuni profili professionali,
i datori di lavoro svizzeri
hanno l'obbligo di convocare a colloquio,
segnalati dagli uffici di collocamento,
cittadini svizzeri,
cioè i cosiddetti "indigeni".
Devono esaminarli e devono valutare
se questi cittadini fanno al caso loro
sulle richieste di assunzione.
Questo non è, come avrete intuito,
l'esito di quella
consultazione referendaria,
perché il datore di lavoro svizzero
convoca l'indigeno,
se l'indigeno non gli sta bene,
lo congeda, lo ringrazia,
non deve motivare
perché non gli sta bene,
e procede ad assumere
un cittadino non elvetico.
Questa è l'essenza di una violazione
della volontà popolare
e di un articolo della Costituzione.
Adesso ve ne racconto un'altra,
che forse è un po' meno eclatante
però altrettanto curiosa e interessante,
sempre relativamente ad un referendum.
Voi saprete che Europol
è una delle agenzie dell'Unione Europea,
è l'agenzia dell'Unione Europea
che si occupa del coordinamento
delle attività di polizia,
che è una cosa estremamente importante,
quindi dello scambio di informazioni
per prevenire la criminalità organizzata,
il terrorismo, eccetera.
Si è deciso che Europol,
a partire dalla primavera prossima,
dovrà diventare qualcosa
di molto più strutturato,
ma soprattutto qualcosa dove i Paesi
decideranno a maggioranza qualificata,
ma non più all'unanimità,
e questo è importante.
Siccome la Danimarca
ha la cosiddetta clausola di "opt out",
che è quella che dà la facoltà al Paese
di chiamarsi fuori da accordi
dove non sia prevista l'unanimità,
il governo danese ha convocato
a dicembre del 2015 un referendum,
nel quale si chiedeva
di rinunciare a questa clausola
e di sostituirla
con una clausola di "opt in".
Cioè, il Paese entrava
in un accordo dove si votava
a maggioranza qualificata
e non più all'unanimità.
Anche qui clamoroso, la popolazione,
con un margine un po' più ampio
di quanto accaduto in Svizzera,
ha votato per respingere questa proposta.
Questo che cosa ha determinato?
Ha determinato, ipso facto,
che la Danimarca è praticamente,
da dicembre 2015, fuori da Europol.
Ora, siccome il coordinamento serve,
ecco che anche qui è iniziato
un processo febbrile,
a mezzo del quale,
si cerca di salvare
la forma del referendum
e la sostanza
della cooperazione di polizia,
perché semplicemente,
pensare di non poter effettuare
l'interscambio di informazioni tra i Paesi
o farlo da posizioni di retrovia,
o depotenziate,
è un rischio che nessun governo
e nessun Paese può permettersi.
Quindi anche qui, dopo circa un anno
di elaborazioni febbrili,
cosa si è deciso?
Il Parlamento Europeo
proprio pochi giorni fa
ha raccomandato questa prassi.
Si è deciso che, per il futuro,
dei funzionari danesi siederanno
nella struttura di Europol,
nell'agenzia fisica di Europol,
in una stanza diversa
da quella dove sono seduti
tutti gli altri esponenti di Paesi
che hanno aderito alla cooperazione
a maggioranza qualificata.
Se un agente di polizia danese
o se un'autorità di polizia danese
ha bisogno di avere uno scambio
di informazioni con Europol,
telefona o manda un flusso di dati
ai propri rappresentanti danesi
che sono seduti in questa stanza.
Il rappresentante danese
si alza dalla sua stanza,
va nella stanza a fianco
e sottopone la richiesta
ai colleghi europei
che fanno parte
a pieno titolo di Europol.
Anche in questo caso,
voi capite che la situazione
è abbastanza tragicomica.
Nel senso,
noi abbiamo, praticamente,
da un lato la volontà popolare,
dall'altro lato,
che cosa?
L'esigenza di cooperazione
e, se volete, anche il vincolo di realtà.
Allora come si lega questa aneddotica,
che vi ho raccontato sin qui,
con l'introduzione?
Quella degli U-Boot,
come catturare gli U-Boot?
Nel senso che,
non ho scoperto nulla di clamoroso,
per cui non non stiamo facendo la storia
in questo momento.
C'è una insopprimibile esigenza,
nell'essere umano,
di ridurre l'ansia e l'effetto ansiogeno
della complessità ambientale.
La complessità ambientale
che c'era già ai tempi degli U-Boot,
quindi durante
la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
e che nella nostra società attuale
è amplificata in maniera esponenziale.
Quindi noi siamo sottoposti
ad un continuo bombardamento
informativo, sensoriale,
di una irruzione dell'alieno
nelle nostre vite,
tutto quello che magari,
delle vite ad alta varianza,
ad alta variabilità,
e quindi questo che cosa provoca?
Provoca insicurezza e ansia.
A volte provoca anche
insicurezza economica,
che poi, a sua volta, genera
un'ansia altrettanto potente.
Quindi qual'è la domanda
e l'esigenza che sorge
in un contesto del genere?
Il fatto di trovare quelli
che io definisco i proiettili d'argento,
cioè delle soluzioni rapide, semplici,
immediate, a problemi complessi.
Tuttavia questa è una fallacia,
perché non esiste nessun proiettile
d'argento in una società complessa,
ma soprattutto in una società
che per sua natura
sta continuamente evolvendo
verso una esigenza
di cooperazione e coordinamento.
Cioè noi siamo condannati,
che ci piaccia o meno,
a interagire con chi ci sta vicino
su vari piani, a vari livelli di distanza,
e a creare un continuo negoziato
con questi soggetti.
Quando le cose vanno bene,
cioè quando il contesto esterno
ci è favorevole,
questa cooperazione non ci costa molto.
Alla fine è una soluzione win-win
di cui tutti siamo molto soddisfatti.
Quando la situazione peggiora,
quando ad esempio,
c'è un problema economico
abbastanza generalizzato,
quando ci sono delle incertezze,
delle incoerenze, eccetera,
e quando le risorse a disposizione
per raggiungere l'obiettivo calano,
ecco che in noi insorge e subentra
questa profonda insoddisfazione
per gli esiti del negoziato.
Il negoziato viene visto
come un crescente fastidio:
il negoziato come
insostenibile vincolo esterno
sulla nostra libertà,
sulla nostra autodeterminazione,
sulla capacità di essere padroni
del nostro destino
e di riprendere il controllo.
Purtroppo, in questa fase,
quella della grande insoddisfazione,
perché il minimo comune
denominatore non ci basta,
ci dà degli esiti insoddisfacenti
e frustranti,
compare nella comunicazione politica,
ma anche nel desiderio
di sedare quest'ansia,
il proiettile d'argento.
Cioè la soluzione immediata,
tanto immediata quanto fallace,
a problemi complessi.
Questo che cosa determina?
Che chiunque tenti di applicare
una soluzione di questo tipo,
va incontro a delle delusioni
e a delle disillusioni
che a volte possono essere
particolarmente traumatiche
e possono generare
degli effetti di stress e di frustrazione
che a volte possono anche minacciare
l'essenza stessa della società,
lacerandone il tessuto.
Quindi qual è il messaggio
che io vorrei dare,
sperando che riesca comunque
ad essere un messaggio ottimistico?
Per me la cooperazione
è qualcosa di faticoso,
qualcosa però che è anche imprescindibile,
perché non esistono soluzioni semplici
a problemi complessi.
Chiunque venga da voi a dirvi:
"Ma guarda che è facilissimo,
si può fare così
e abbiamo risolto il problema",
dovrebbe suscitare una sorta di...
dovrebbe far suonare,
dovrebbe far accendere
un campanello d'allarme.
Perché queste sono
le situazioni di reale pericolo,
perché il vincolo di realtà
e la complessità
ci condannano alla cooperazione
ma possono essere qualcosa
che è tanto faticoso quanto gratificante,
se si riesce a portare
fuori questo discorso.
In conclusione,
quello che io vorrei dire,
ispirandomi ad una quote,
ad una citazione di Graucho Marx,
è che, come vedete,
non è che mi faccia impazzire la realtà
e il suo vincolo di realtà,
ma tuttavia la realtà è l'unico posto
dove io posso ottenere un pasto decente.
Questa frase a me piace moltissimo perché,
in un momento in cui la comunicazione
tende ad essere ipersemplificata,
però in funzione ansiolitica,
e a offrire pasti gratis,
che di fatto non esistono,
la metafora del pasto
allora dovrebbe aiutarci a pensare
in maniera un po' più
approfondita e strutturata.
Perché dare un pasto gratis,
che non esiste per definizione,
non solo per gli economisti
con tutte le loro fissazioni
e i loro stati psicotici,
e un pasto decente
bisogna sempre e comunque
puntare al pasto decente.
Perché questo serve
ad evitare dei risvegli
particolarmente traumatici.
Vi ringrazio per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)